Carl Weathers sadly passed away on
February 1st few performers had the kind
of range the actor exhibited across
dozens of film and television projects
upon the news of his death social media
was filled with his collaborators and
fans mourning the Beloved actor with
roles in the Rocky movies and Predator
Carl Weathers was probably seen as more
of an action or dramatic actor to much
of the general public however he proved
just how hilarious he could be with a
starring turn in 1996's Happy Gilmore he
plays chubs a former golfer who coaches
happy to utilize his golfing prowess to
the fullest extent waving a fake hand
around all the while think of a place
that's really perfect your own happy
place Sandler took to Instagram to
express his sorrow at weather's passing
reflecting on what a great guy he was
all around Beyond simply being a
tremendous actor a true great man great
dad great actor great athlete so much
fun to be around always smart as hell
loyal as hell fun funny as hell loved
his sons more than anything what a guy
Carl weather's most recent role prior to
his passing was grief carga on the
Mandalorian it's a role he occupied
since the very first episode and he
continued to appear throughout its run
as recently as season 3 carga became one
of den jaren's closest allies and
weathers even directed a couple of
episodes of the Star Wars series he's
been a bright spot in the franchise and
on Instagram Pascal remembers his friend
with a quick statement that sums up the
actor death words fail by the sound of
it weathers had big plans in mind for
continuing car's journey in an interview
with hypebeast weathers detailed what he
foresaw as the future of the character I
can see him not only protecting Navaro
but becoming the tip of the spear and
guarding the planet if there are any
entities that want to come in and take
over I don't think grief carga is going
to be a shy guy in stepping out front
and putting on his Battle Gear aled best
faced a great deal of unfair criticism
after playing Jar Jar Binks in in the
Star Wars prequels in 2023 best returned
to Star Wars playing Kellin Beck in the
foundling an episode of the Mandalorian
that was directed by Carl Weathers on
Instagram best posted a beautiful
statement on Carl Weathers including a
picture of the two of them smiling best
mentions looking up to weathers ever
since he was a kid beyond that best
reflected on how weathers helped him
return to Star Wars he saw how nervous I
was to be back in Star Wars and gave me
the strength and confidence to perform
Legacy sequels are all always a risky
proposition but Creed defied the odds
and launched a whole new franchise from
where the rocky films left off the film
stars Michael B Jordan as Adonis Creed
son of Apollo Creed whom Carl Weathers
played in several movies weathers wasn't
in any of the Creed movies but his
presence could be felt it only makes
sense that Jordan would honor the man
whose footsteps he walks in on his
Instagram stories Jordan posted a
picture of weathers along with the
statement we lost a legend weathers may
not have appeared alongside Jordan in
the Creed films but he loved what the
actor did with the character shortly
after the release of the first Creed
movie weathers posted on X formerly
known as Twitter Michael B Jordan you
did well for the Creed name congrats on
a great job my friend may your success
continue it's safe to say John favro
respected Carl Weathers On another level
as they were both actors who eventually
made their way to director's chairs
additionally the two worked together on
the Mandalorian fav's statement on
weather's passing was posted to Star
wars.com and it honors his lengthy
Legacy favro wrote I Am heartbroken by
this devastating loss he was a hero from
my childhood who I was lucky enough to
meet and then had the amazing Good
Fortune to work with he had the energy
and curiosity of a young man paired with
the wisdom that his rich life and career
afforded him my heart goes out to his
family and countless admirers
Dylan you son of
a with that one statement in Predator
between Dutch and Dylan as well as two
manly hands clasping a mem was born and
the interaction might as well have
really summed up the friendship between
the two actors as Schwarzenegger
reflected on X on losing such an
incredible performer Schwarzenegger
wrote about all weathers managed to
accomplish throughout an extraordinary
career additionally he wrote how he
helped make Predator the influential
film it became he wrote we couldn't have
made Predator without him and we
certainly wouldn't have had such a
wonderful time making it it appears the
feeling was mutual as weathers told red
carpet news TV in 2016 we had a lot of
fun too lots of great guys on that movie
Carl weather's comedic sensibilities and
Happy Gilmore shouldn't have been a
surprise to anyone who watched him host
Saturday Night Live on January 30th 1988
weathers sted an array of sketches
including an installment of Master
thespian a recurring character played by
John litz the show may have happened
over 35 years ago but litz still
remembers what an astounding performer
weathers was on X litz reflected on
getting to work with weathers all those
years ago while also reflecting on how
spectacular he was in Rocky weather's
comedic timing would be on full display
over the years as he would play himself
on Arrested Development and voiced the
basketball King on Regular Show he truly
could do it all Jones referred to
weathers as Apollo Creed in a post to X
while posting a picture of his character
Dylan in Predator another comedian danne
cook offered a tribute on X to weathers
also pointing toward his performance as
Apollo Creed as one for the ages
weathers may be gone but his influence
will remain through an astonishingly
excellent body of work many of his
colleagues will continue to remember him
and that holds true for numerous fans
who cherish weather's
movies